hello and welcome to learning about it
with me Lulu today we're going to be
learning about under promotion under
promotion is when you would promote upon
to a piece that isn't a queen usually
for a tactical reason but sometimes just
for fun but we're gonna go over the
former today all right so here we can
see that White has a pawn pretty far
down on black side of the board so we're
almost ready to get that promotion going
but first can we see a better option to
sort of deflect the King from that
square and maybe give us a chance to
under promote it is Queen takes h7 check
so the King is forced to take this and
now we can promote to a knight forking
the king and queen with check so we're
gonna win that Queen so here we can see
that White has a pawn still pretty close
to the edge of the board ready to
promote but we shouldn't promote to a
queen because as we can see here black
has nowhere to go so this is a stalemate
but if we promote to a rook instead the
team has to move and then it's checkmate
so that's pretty good okay so today we
learned about under promotion which is
when you promote to a piece that isn't a
queen under protion does it happen too
often in our games but when it does it's
rare and beautiful like a unicorn so
thanks for learning about it with me
Lulu and make sure to LIKE and subscribe